here with reaction South Carolina
Senator Lindsey Graham is with us so you
got 10 million or so unvetted Joe Biden
illegal immigrants uh we're paying for
food water housing Education Health Care
cities overwhelmed even Democratic
Mayors and governors have had it uh and
yet they've been telling us the whole
time that the border is secure and
closed it's not um and look at the
impact I mean what is the end game here
why do they have no interest do they not
did did they not get alarm bells in
their mind when you hear people from
Iran and Syria and Egypt and Afghanistan
and Russia and China there because
that's where they're coming from yeah
well fentol poisoning of our young
people is the leading cause of death
among Americans from 18 to35 is coming
across the Mexican border it's made in
China comes to Mexico comes across the
border the drug cartels human
traffickers of been the biggest
beneficiary uh of the Biden presidency
why is president president Trump leading
in South Carolina by 30 points the
people of South Carolina believ that
Donald Trump was the best Republican
president since Ronald Reagan people in
South Carolina do not believe that Trump
creates chaos they believe that Donald
Trump can clean up the chaos being
created by Biden that Donald Trump is
our best hope to secure the border to
make us energy independent to manage the
economy and to put out all the fires in
the world Nikki Haley is a good person
10 Scott is one of my best friends I
endorse Donald Trump on day one because
I saw from a front row position of four
years of the toughest guy I've ever seen
in Washington who brought the world to a
better place on National Security than
anybody since Reagan who made his strong
at home uh and strong overseas Donald
Trump's going to win South Carolina big
not because we don't like Nikki Haley we
do we just believe Donald Trump is the
the best person to be president and
without Donald Trump there are no Trump
policies can you explain this to me
we're going to have an Open Primary if
Donald Trump wins the general election
or not he's won decisively in both New
Hampshire and Iowa that's not happened
since
1976 she's not competing in Nevada uh so
now we have uh South Carolina next and
she's down real clear politics average
down 30 points why would she risk losing
in her home state by such a big mark
when she could come back in in 3 4 years
and and run a campaign in an Open
Primary where I think her anybody's odds
would be better don't you think well
Nikki Haley has been her friend for a
very long time she was a two-term
governor and people like her her numbers
are good at home why is she losing to
president Trump it's no fault of her is
the assets and attributes of President
Trump I can't express enough to the
people watching your show that those of
us in South Carolina who respect Nikki
Haley believe that Donald Trump is the
most capable person to be president that
can beat Joe Biden but not just beat Joe
Biden clean up a broken border scare the
hell out of the terrorist help Israel
who's under siege make us energy
independent again why do I say that
because he did it before nobody running
on the Republican side can say they've
been president except him Donald Trump
and when you compare his presidency to
that of Joe Biden he's going to beat Joe
Biden uh like a drum that's why he's
going to win South Carolina that's why
he's going to be the next president of
the United States he's the best person
to do the job and to clean up the mess
created by Joe
bu and by the way the way that Tim
Scott's been treated by liberals in the
media the way all many African Americans
are treated that are conservative uh in
the media it's it's repulsive uh anyway
good to have you back hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else